airbnb have got massive problems
on their hands right now brian chesky
who's the ceo of airbnb
and anyone who doesn't know what airbnb
do airbnb are basically like a hotel
business they don't own any hotels
but you can list your property so for
instance this property i could list this
property as a holiday home
and say hey as it happens i rent this
house
i'd pay a monthly rent on this house in
fact if i wanted to
i could get the landlord permission and
i could rent this house but not living
it myself
i could rent it and then i could list it
on a website such as
airbnb and then i could rent it out
every month every every day or every
week
and charge a much higher amount see i've
got a long-term lease on this
so i i pay i wouldn't say a small amount
of rent
but if i rented this out as a holiday
home by the week
the cash flow on top would be would be a
lot that's what airbnb does that's what
it allows you to do
or if you own a property a lot of the
properties that i own
rather than renting them out to tenants
what's the problem to rent to the amount
of tenants well you're going to get a
limited amount of rent because the
tenant's going to be staying there a
long time
so they want to pay they want to get
like the same as anything if you're
buying a whole bunch of hot dogs
you expect to get a reduced rate whereas
if you're just buying one
you'll pay a premium why because you'll
buy if you're buying something in bulk
you want to get a discount in the same
way if i'm renting this house and i'm
saying i'm going to sign a two-year
lease
per week i'm going to pay much much less
than i would if i said i want it for the
weekend
so that and that's rent to rent that's
what rent to rent is
now why have airbnb got a problem
why has brian chesky come out and said
he's got a massive issue
right now in 2021
and the reason is is because he says
that they need
a million new hosts
a million new hosts what that simply
means is
which is really important that simply
means is there's
more people right now
trying to rent houses on airbnb
trying to stay at holiday homes
than there are holiday homes available
that's the problem that's why he needs a
million
new airbnb hosts now
what why is this happening well i think
the reason this is happening
is because the lockdown's lifting right
now
and everyone's desperate to go on
holiday now right now we can't
necessarily travel internationally
so what people are doing is they're
doing something called staycations a
staycation is where you stay in your
country
but so you'll stay out you'll stay in
your home country but you're still going
like a little mini a little mini break
a little mini holiday so you might say i
want to go and stay in this house
for a week that's like a holiday but
it's in your country so people are doing
that at the moment like absolute crazy
they're doing staycations but there's
nowhere to book for them
because everywhere's all booked up why
because everyone's looking
so what brian chesky's saying is he's
saying if you own a home
please list it as a hotel
on airbnb because we need more hosts
we need more airbnb hosts well what does
that mean
that means that for you watching this
video if you're a property owner
instead of renting out to tenants
tenants have got
so many rights there's a tenant eviction
ban at the moment
which means that you can't evict your
tenant if the tenant stops paying rent
don't rent your houses to tenants rent
your houses to guests
and you're gonna get three four five six
times the profit
than you would if you rented it out as a
normal to a normal tenancy and
guests don't have rights if i if i
if i moved into this house for a week
and at the end of the week if i went
actually you know what
i don't want to move out um they'd say
well you have to
they'll just kick me out i'm straight
i'm a guest
if i'm a tenant and i say i don't want
to move out
i go oh okay we'll work with you and i
have to give you
so many months notice and even then
we'll then take you to court and it's a
big long procedure
so you're much better off to rent to
guests rather than tenants
from a cash flow perspective and also
from a
uh an easy life perspective now you
might say but then samuel then you're
gonna have to go and
let them in the house and you're gonna
need all the hassle you have to clean it
change the beddings
you don't have to do that you're going
to use system i mean i actually run i
run a training program
called the serviced accommodation
intensive where i train people how to
systemize their house
like a hotel by doing things like
putting a key safe
outside so when you arrive you don't
need a reception
this isn't a hotel it's a holiday home
it's just vacation you're a host but you
don't have to actually physically be
there
you arrive and you're going to have a
little keypad a little key safe
key code you can buy them for 15 pounds
from argos and then when your guest
books on they're going to get an
automated email
and you're going to say hey when you
arrive it's going to be a little video
of you
this is the key side come on in you got
a little guest pack
and you have cleaners super cleaners
that manage your diary
to manage the diary of the guests and
come in and come out
and you're going to pay them out the
profits and you don't need a nice
big house like this you can you can do
this with apartments
you don't need to own the apartments you
can rent an apartment
for like five six hundred pounds
off of a landlord maybe even less
maybe you said to the landlord look
landlord i'll rent this apartment off
you
but i will um i'll have a com
a company there corporate let so i'm not
a tenant
i haven't got rights i'm a company i'm
gonna do a corporate lap
um something and then you put guests in
and you keep the profit
it's never been a better time to do this
airbnb right now crying out how much do
airbnb charge
well they don't really charge anything
they just take a small
it's about two percent fee and you can
put an
you can take a property you can list it
on airbnb
in about 15 minutes boom get it live
and then you've got yourself a hotel
effectively
without having to have staff without
having to own the property
this is how many of my students are
becoming financially free from property
they don't own
taking advantage of the economy so right
now
maybe all your friends and your
broke-ass poor family
are moaning about the economy oh isn't
it hard it's hard to get jobs at the
moment
listen i'm working class i grew up i
wouldn't say poor but definitely not
rich
no one gave me any money no one gave me
a penny i started
because i realized 12 years ago that
rather than relying on the economy
i realized that i could create my own
economy
how do you create your own economy by
finding
problems and right now airbnb have got a
massive problem
and that is that they haven't got enough
hosts they haven't gotten there isn't
enough accommodation
you find the problem and then you come
and bring a solution
which is maybe you go and rent some
houses with permission from the landlord
with the right
agreements in place to list those
properties on airbnb
and then you become a super host and you
take the monthly profit every month
pay the landlord his rent keep the
difference
after costs each property that you own
sorry each property that you control
should make you between 500 pounds
and 2 000 pounds a month how many of
those do you need
if you make it your mission over the
next
two months if you say right the next two
months i'm going to get five of those
properties i'm not going to own them i
have no money right now to start with
i'm just going to control them i'm just
going to rent properties
with the right contracts and then i'm
going to become a host on airbnb
of course you need to do due diligence
you need to do the right area
but people are crying out right now for
hotels for accommodation so create your
own economy
become financially free this is not just
happening
in america or in the uk this is pretty
much all over the world
so if you're in australia if you're in
asia
in america across europe tap into these
strategies
and make it happen so massive
announcement really exciting news for me
anyway
and i hope to see you super successful
subscribe
i'll see you next time